Putin did not want this war he went to
Great Lengths before February 24th
2022 when the war started to head it off
at the past he wanted to come up with a
diplomatic solution and then shortly
after the war broke out in February he
was negotiating with the ukrainians uh
to work out a deal and at that point in
time he was not talking about
incorporating any Ukrainian territory
safe Forme Crimea which had already been
annexed into Russia and all he really
cared about it's quite clear from all
the reports of the people who were
involved in the discussions was NATO
expansion into Ukraine he wanted a
neutral Ukraine and if he had gotten a
neutral Ukraine this is right after the
war started I believe there's a good
chance the war could have been shut down